[Musik]
hallo kinder playstation haushalt aus
der hose jetzt reden wir mal über
siemens asozialem ist firma ab sofort
boykottiert das hier ist das letzte
siemens handy dass ich mir je kaufen
werde
da läuft nicht mal kinder drauf ich will
die ganze zeit wie blöd und vielen dank
joe kaeser der oberste käse vom siemens
schließt die standorte görlitz und
leipzig genau diese werke hat der
konzern doch millionen an ost
subventionen kassiert tal die ganze
summe zusammen mit den fantastilliarden
statt kohle für eure atomkraftwerke
schon der allererste siemens auftrag kam
vom staat kein witz 1847 die telegrafen
leitung von berlin nach frankfurt und
das erste telegramm ging dann an die
handwerker bbb
ihr seid alle entlassen klickt euch
siemens was mich am meisten aufregt der
käser ist ständig dabei wenn die marke
linz am platz liegt acht mal allein in
dieser legislatur saudi arabien china
usa
der britische merkel flieger ekelhaft
alles damit noch mehr siemens könnte ins
ausland fertigt wird wovon die
belegschaft wie wir gelernt haben im
ernstfall einen scheiß
dafür macht er aber der taxlerin
geschenke bis hin zum eigenen parfum
wenn ich selber zur fabrik kommen und
mir mein flacon abholen will jetzt auch
einen film machen machen wir erstmal
angeles street die sogar da fällt mir
ein spitzen mit 1 0 für dich jo lang
gesetz eigentum verpflichtet sein
gebrauch soll zugleich dem wohle der
allgemeinheit dienen
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
ich meine prozent aber das läuft ja
nicht die menschen geht
text
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit kasper